welcome to this video I'm playing
Mikolka 1985 GM from Italy Italian flag
what's the name Nikita on my yer off
yellow 25 70 something all right it is
to 540 m and five miniatures okay so I
wanted to play the kings in the enmity
went from pretty rare set up involving
b4 c4 I'm not bad this is not a bad line
it has been played on me amongst others
by am former world champion versus him
Vasily smooth love and smooth love was
really young master of harmony and chess
he M really know how to set up a good
solid position ok so I'm pretty
surprised that we had this we got this
kind of structure going on the queenside
where it's not obvious how white is
going to make any progress I'm not
intending to close up the position here
it since I think it's just good to take
and play 94 uh-huh this is interesting
ok let's let's take the square on c5
shouldn't be bad yes he may be intense
to to play some the piece on c6 at the
end this is some weekend square of
course
all right what can you do it's just one
square many others on the board okay so
how to continue yeah I could exchange
couple of pieces here with 94
simplifying the position now why not the
knight on c6 it's not really doing so
much I mean it's it takes to move to get
there even but it's not a big big deal
yeah this is another possibility of
course
okay of course I need to get rid of the
d5 not intending to play Knight f6
this is in fact interesting no it's a
sex mmm
this is a bit tricky I underestimated
that mule okay kaveh c7 so that my queen
can actually move after 96 okay so where
should I go I wanted to play Knight f6
but then knight c6 is really
embarrassing this is the preparation for
Knight f6 really if I go nite have six
now mmm YUM you can play you can play a
g3 almighty five possibly
they are up t fall so hmm
well
hmm this is not not a nice position at
all to put it lightly night f successive
rookie form and ng three in addition Wow
yeah what to see but this yeah i don't
know i don't see I don't see a good move
at all
yeah he can play 97 but I the nights are
are so terrible I don't really mind to
give up in exchange at the moment hey of
course I'm lost their birthday but the
the exchange doesn't really matter so
much yeah this was this was a really bad
he really outplayed me nicely here but I
completely underestimated this this
Knight d4 c6 idea okay the positive
thing is that this isn't isn't so easy
because my night and queen are still
quite um quite annoying okay so probably
just get this night and hear the king as
well
f3 I can take g3 do this I don't
understand to be honest and they're so
so lost here that you can do that even I
don't know Knight g4 now is this
dangerous this looks dangerous mmm it is
dangerous can take care now check so
so I'm in good shape now for some reason
f4 strange very strange I talking before
I can just play king before okay that's
not a big deal rook a7 I can just take
me three but but still checks also not
really a necessary thing to do
yeah this is some quite quite a big big
figure pause here check time 22 seconds
check
and to connect it passes it's a bit much
yeah always need to be a bit cautious
with the premium check you never know if
they play some some silly move that just
to text your look check
check check check check check this is
why I like increment blitz check white
for hey you come in time he forfeited on
time oh this is funny but didn't expect
that but okay I mean what can you do he
really i'll play me completely and here
I really underestimated that I need to
really check this what black now I mean
the idea was was clear that this arm
this a week but it really worked out to
perfection for white how should I play
that he has this already as some
probably slightly slightly and precise
maybe maybe this is an idea now i don't
know like this
maybe hear something I need to be
precisely i don't think i can be much
worse the way I played I was much worse
no doubt this is already very very
tricky the two nights here I just just
terrible ah here f three wins I mean
instantly wins yes of course I'm ah f3
you played this one yeah but f3 really
kills immediately I have no move
whatsoever yeah and then Dover I mean
where where should I go check check I'm
losing everything here wow wow now okay
I can also go here and now my queen is
immediately trapped yeah he can
completely destroyed me the only one I
would absolutely didn't understand I
mean age four already I didn't quite
quite get I mean f3 was stronger
probably chat but here I mean white
should win but it's already much more
than then I deserved in the game and
here I'm not sure at all Queen age three
and stuff like that this is already
tricky the computer wants to play f3
here and this sir this already after
Queen a tree is better for black
substantially even check yeah this is
just winning for black yeah what can you
do he just let me off the hook very
badly alright thanks for watching